[Music]
in 1808 four companies of the second
battalion to which i belonged
were ordered to portugal and that year
i first saw the french being immediately
pushed forwards up the country in
advance of the main body
many of us in this hot climate very soon
began to find out the misery
of the frightful load we were condemned
to march and fight under
with a burning sun above our heads and
our feet
sinking every step into the hot sand
[Music]
though the peasantry sent into our camp
a great quantity of the good things of
their country
so that our men regaled themselves upon
oranges grapes
melons and figs and we had an abundance
of delicacies which many of us had never
before tasted
among other presents a live calf was
presented to the rifles
so that altogether we feasted in our
first entrance into portugal
like a company of aldermen the next day
we again advanced and being in a state
of the utmost anxiety to come up against
the french
neither the heat of the burning sun long
miles or heavy knapsacks were able to
diminish our ardour
indeed i often look back with wonder at
the lighthearted style the jolity
and reckless indifference with which men
who were destined in so shorter time to
fall
hurried onwards to the field of strife
seemingly without a thought of anything
but the sheer love of meeting the foe
and the excitement of the battle
this video is sponsored by skillshare
the online learning platform
skillshare is a great resource that i've
been using to brush up on my editing
and general business skills one example
that has had a huge effect on voices of
the past
was the session creative video
storytelling and editing
making the most of stock footage by
nikki stevens
with the quarantine over the last year
using stock footage effectively has been
an absolute lifesaver for a lot of the
videos
from the history brothers and that's
skillshare whether you're a professional
or just starting out it's a great
resource for self-improvement
and to start you off the first 1000 of
my subscribers to click the link in the
description
we'll get a free trial of premium
membership so you can explore your
creativity
and make the most of 2021 thanks
on the 17th being still in front we came
up with the french
and i remember observing the pleasing
effect afforded by the sun's rays
glancing upon their arms as they formed
in order of battle to receive us
moving on in extended order under
whatever cover the nature of the ground
afforded
we began a sharp fire upon them and thus
commenced
the battle of rolisa
i do not pretend to give a description
of this or any other battle i've been
present at
all i can do is to tell the things which
happened immediately around me
and that i think as much as a private
soldier can be expected to do
the rifles indeed fought well this day
and we lost many men
they seemed in high spirits and
delighted at having driven the enemy
before them
joseph cochran was by my side loading
and firing very industriously about this
period of the day
thirsting with heat in action he lifted
his canteen to his mouth
here's to you old boy he said as he took
a pull of its contents
as he did so a bullet went through the
canteen and perforating his brain killed
him in a moment
another man fell close to him almost
immediately struck by a ball
in the thigh indeed we caught it
severely just here
and saw a man named simmons struck full
in the face by a round shot
and he came to the ground a headless
trunk
a man near me uttered a scream of agony
and looking from the 29th who were on my
right
to the left and once the screech had
come i saw one of our sergeants
named frasier sitting in a doubled up
position and swaying backwards and
forwards
as though he had got a terrible pain in
his bowels he continued to
make so much complaint that i arose and
went to him for he was rather a crony of
mine
oh harris said he as i took him in my
arms
i shall die i shall die the agony is so
great that i cannot bear it
it was indeed dreadful to look upon him
the froth came from his mouth
and the perspiration poured from his
face thank heaven he was
soon out of pain and laying him down i
returned to my place
poor fellow he suffered more for the
short time that he was dying than any
man i think i ever saw in the same
circumstances
i had the curiosity to return and look
at him after the battle
a musket ball i found had taken him
sideways
and gone through both groins
within about half an hour after this i
left sergeant frasier
and indeed for the time had us
completely forgotten him
as if he had died 100 years back the
sight of so much bloodshed around will
not suffer the mind to dwell
too long in any particular casualty even
though it happens to one's dearest
friend
there was no time either to think for
all the action with us rifles just at
this moment
and the barrel of my piece was so hot
from continual firing
that i could hardly bear to touch it and
was obliged to grasp the stock beneath
the iron as i continued to blaze away
james ponton was another crony of miner
a gallant fellow
he had pushed himself in front of me and
was checked by one of our officers
for his rashness keep back you ponton
the lieutenant had said to him more than
once but ponton was not to be restrained
by anything
but a bullet when in action this time
he got one which striking him in the
thigh
i suppose hit an artery if he died
quickly
the frenchman's balls were flying very
wickedly at that moment and i crept up
to ponton
and took shelter by lying behind and
making a rest for my rifle
of his dead body it strikes me that i
revenged his death by the assistance of
his carcass
at any rate i tried my best to hit the
enemies hard
after the battle was over i stepped
across to a nearby house
in order to see what was going on there
two or three surgeons also
arrived at this house and were busily
engaged in giving their assistance to
the wounded
but what struck me most forcibly was
that from the circumstance of some wine
butts having been left in the apartment
and they're having in the engagement
being perforated by bullets or otherwise
broken
the red wine had escaped most
plentifully and ran
down upon the earthen floor where the
wounded were lying
so that many of them were soaked in the
wine with which their blood
was mingled
when the roll was called after the
battle the females who missed their
husbands came along in front of the line
to inquire of the survivors whether they
knew anything about them
amongst other names i heard that of
cochin called in a female voice
without being replied to the name struck
me
and i observed the poor woman who had
called it as she stood sobbing before us
and apparently afraid to make further
enquiries about her husband
no man had answered to his name or had
any account to give of his fate
i myself had observed him full as
related before while drinking from his
canteen
but as i looked at the poor sobbing
creature before me i felt unable to tell
her of his death
captain leeched observed her and called
out to the company does any man here
know what has happened to cochran
upon this order i immediately related
what i had seen and told the manner of
his death
go then said the captain and show the
poor woman the spot
as she seems so desirous of finding the
body
i accordingly took my way over the
ground we had fought upon
she following and sobbing after me and
quickly reaching the spot where her
husband's body lay
pointed out to her
it was on the 21st of august that we
commenced fighting the battle of vimero
the french came down upon us in a column
and the riflemen immediately commenced a
sharp fire upon them from whatever they
could get a shelter behind
whilst our cannon played upon them one
of our corporals
named murphy was the first man in the
rifles who was hit that morning
and i remember more particularly
remarking the circumstance
from his apparently having a premonition
of his fate before the battle began
he was usually an active fellow and up
to the time he had shown himself a good
and brave soldier
but on this morning he seemed unequal to
his duty
and as we had reason to know he was not
ordinarily deficient in courage
the circumstance was talked of after the
battle was over
he was the first man shot that day
early on the morning of the battle i
remember being relieved from picket
and throwing myself down to gain a few
hours sleep before the expected
engagement
so wearied was i was watching that i was
hardly lying down before i was in a
sound
sleep asleep which those only who have
toiled in the field can know
i was not however destined to enjoy a
very long repose before one of our
sergeants
poking me with the muzzle of his rifle
desired me to get up
as many of the men wanted their shoes
repaired immediately
this was by no means an uncommon
occurrence on looking around in order to
observe if there was any hut or shed in
which i could more conveniently exercise
my craft
i spied a house near at hand on the rise
of a small hill
so i gathered up several pairs of the
dilapidated boots and shoes
and immediately made for it seating
myself down in a small room as soon as i
entered
i took the tools from my haversack and
prepared to work
and as the boots of the captain of my
company were amongst the bad lot
and he was barefooted for one of them i
commenced with them
hardly had i worked a quarter of an hour
on a canon ball
the first announcement of the coming
battle came crashing through the walls
of the house
just above my head and completely
covered the captain's boot
as it lay between my knees there were
only two persons in the room at the time
an old
and a young woman and they were so
dreadfully scared of this sudden
visitation
that they ran around the room making the
house echo with their shrieks
for my own part although i was more used
to such
sounds i thought it was no time and
place to mend boots and shoes
and so being thus left alone in my glory
i shook the dust from my apron gathered
up the whole stocking trade from the
floor
and hastily replacing my tools in my
haversack followed the example of the
mistress of the mansion and her daughter
and bolted
out of the house when i got into the
open air i
found all in a state of bustle and
activity the men falling in and the
officers busily engaged
while 20 or 30 mouths opened at me the
moment i appeared
calling out for their boots and shoes
where's my boots harris your humbug
give me my shoes your old sinner the
captain's boots here harris instantly
make haste and fall into the ranks as
quickly as you can
there was indeed no time for ceremony so
letting go the corners of my apron i
threw down a whole lot of boots and
shoes for the men to choose for
themselves
captain leech ordered a section of our
men to move off at double quick and take
possession of a windmill which was on
our left
i was amongst this section and set off
full cry towards the mill
and captain leech spied and ruled out to
me by name and to return
hello you there harris he called fall
out of that section directly
we want you here my man i therefore
wheeled out of the rank and returned to
him
you fall in amongst the men here harris
i shall not send you to that post
the cannon will play upon the mill in a
few moments like hail
and what should we do he continued
laughing without our head shoemaker
to repair our shoes
i myself was very soon so hotly engaged
loading and firing away
enveloped in the smoke i created and the
cloud which hung about me from the
continued fire of my comrades
that i could see nothing for a few
minutes but the red flash of my own
piece
amongst the white vapor clinging to my
very clothes
this has often seemed to me the very
greatest drawback upon our present
system of fighting
forced in such state on a calm day until
some friendly breeze of wind clears the
space around
a soldier knows no more of his position
and what is about to happen in his front
or what has happened than the very dead
lying around whilst groans and shouts
and the noise of cannon and musketry
appeared to almost shake the very ground
it seemed hell on earth i thought
it was just at the close of the battle
of vimero the dreadful toil and noise of
the engagement had hardly subsided
and i began to look into the faces of
the men around me to see who had escaped
the dangers of the hour
four or five days back i'd done the same
thing at rolitha
one feels indeed a sort of curiosity to
know after such a scene who was
remaining alive amongst the companions
endeared by good conduct
or disliked from bad character during
the hardships of the campaign
i saw that the ranks of the rifleman
looked very thin
it seemed to me one half had gone down
the battle was just over
a flag of truce had come over from the
french a frenchman
lay close beside me he was dying and
called to me for water
i need not say that i got up and i gave
it to him
worcester did so down galloped the major
in front just in the same good spirits
he'd been in all day
plunging along avoiding with some little
difficulty the dead and dying
which was strewn about he was a regular
gooden a real english soldier
and that's better than if he'd been the
handsomest ladies man in the army
the manger just now disclosed what none
of us i believe knew before
namely that his head was as bald as a
coot's and that he had covered the
nakedness of his knob
up to the present time by a flowing
caxon which during the heat of the
action had somehow been dislodged
and was lost a guinea he kept crying as
he rode
to any man he will find my wig the men i
remember notwithstanding the side of the
wounded and dead around them
burst into shouts of laughter as he went
and a guinea to any man who will find my
wig
was the saying amongst us long after
that affair
and here let me bear testimony to the
courage and endurance of that army
under trials and hardships such as few
armies in any age
i should think endured i've seen
officers and men hobbling forward
with tears in their eyes from the misery
of long miles empty stomachs
and ragged backs without even shoes or
stockings on their bleeding feet
and it was not a little that would bring
a tear into the eyes of a rifleman of
the peninsula
youths who had not long been removed
from their parents home and care
officers and men have borne hardships
and probations
such as we have little conception of
and yet these men faint and weary with
toil
would brighten up in a moment when the
word ran amongst us
that the enemy were at hand